We left off in the last video is King James is six and the first the same
person,
but the monarch.
Importantly of two countries,
England and Scotland.
Two very important things happened during the royal of James.
The first for the first time,
as I said,
England,
Scotland and Ireland are all undisputably ruled by the same monarch and what is
called a union of Crowns.
Now,
Scotland and England still our main separate countries,
but they politically had the same king and this would ultimately foreshadow the
coming of the United Kingdom of Great Britain and Ireland.
Ireland had been capitulated prior to this during the reign of Henry to seven
and this essentially secures for the first time England's perhaps 800 years
struggle to dominate the British isles.
Secondly,
with Spain defeated in the reign of Elizabeth.
England has a path now to colonize the Americas.
They set up to colony of James town named after,
believe it or not,
King James in Modern Day Virginia,
which becomes the first permanent English colony in North America.
And somewhat further say the founding of Jamestown marks the beginning of the
British empire,
which we'll see more of throughout this video.
Religious conflicts continued throughout Europe and England.
Three major assassination attempts were made on the king,
including the famous gunpowder treason on the 5th of November,
undertaken to place a Catholic monarch on the throne of England.
But James would reign through what is called the Jacobean era.
We're in England,
essentially laid the seeds for Northern Ireland via the plantation.
Oh certain things like that.
The Bible was translated into English as the King James Bible and King James led
England during a turbulent period of English history.
And on March 27 1625 when he died of a stroke,
James had been openly bisexual and preferred men to women,
but his position naturally put pressure on him to marry and produce an heir.
He fell in love with an of Denmark and had three children with her.
One of these children,
Charles succeeded him to the throne.
Charles was thrown into intensifying religious disagreement and conflict in
Europe and in England.
He ruled during the 30 years war.
Europe's bloodiest religious conflict fought largely between Protestants and
Catholics.
It would claim the lives of millions.
The fact that Charles had attempted to force his Anglican religion on other
emerging Protestant groups in England.
The fact that he hadn't married a Catholic despite being an Anglican and the
fact that he had promised his support militarily,
the French against the Protestant rebels,
then a ride and instead on successfully use ships to assist a Protestant rebels
against the French at the siege of La Rochelle and his dissolution of parliament
when they refuse to provide him with the power to raise taxes,
created multiple conflicts for him,
which would eventually spiral out of control.
As he attempted to bring his Anglican religious doctrine that Scotland,
they resisted it starting what is called the bishop's,
were seeing his religious conversion attempts in Scotland failing,
which was in reality and attempt to further secure Scotland and England to a
permanent union via religion and Washington.
Scottish actually invade England in retaliation.
Charles has said it to ask parliament for funds to support his armies.
Parliaments being sympathetic actually to the Scottish concerns and with disdain
for Charles.
His efforts refuses.
Charles unhappy with this decision ordered parliament to be dissolved.
Parliaments simply refuse to be dissolved following these disagreements or
conflicts between royal and parliamentary authority in England lead to the
English civil,
the English civil war,
kind of like a hundred years where it wasn't just one big war.
It's more commonly seen as three wars in one.
The country divided between parliamentarians called the round heads who were
largely supported by Protestants and common or as in like as opposed to the
royalist it Cavaliers who were supported by of course an ability but also a
catholic.
Seeing Charles as sympathetic to their interests.
Leading the new model army of the parliamentarians was Lord Thomas Fairfax and
Oliver Cromwell.
Two very important figures.
The first two wars last from 1642 to 1649 the second one being finished with the
battle of Preston,
which the parliamentarian,
the one and King Charles there after became subject to that immense.
Now in the past,
looking back at for example of something like King John,
when rebel forces defeated the king or the aristocracy in general,
often what followed was that they forced him to concede to their demands and it
was definitely not smooth sailing from there,
but the monarchy generally remained intact here.
Parliament decides that maybe they don't need a king after all.
They go so far as to put King Charles on trial,
which had never been done before and they find him guilty of high treason and
behead him.
On January 30th,
1649 following this parliament rules England,
England becomes essentially a form of a republic.
They formed the counsel of the state and they are immediately confronted by
Charles.
His Song,
Charles is second trying to reclaim the power,
which is the third phase of the English civil war.
But in 1651 prominent wins again,
the Commonwealth of England,
a Republican government uniting England,
Wales,
Scotland,
and Ireland is truly formed parliament,
places of bounty on Charles his head,
but he was successfully able to escape to Normandy in 1653 Oliver Cromwell was
power grows and he takes on the title and the powers of Lord protector of the
Commonwealth,
which was a position which as his critics of the day pointed out,
made him king and all,
but name Cranwell remains to this day a very controversial figure.
He has remembered favorably for his actions on behalf of the common people
ending Menargo power and moving England into a Republican oriented government,
but unfavorably as well for the power he's Sim during his rural seen as a
dictator responsible for pressing Catholics in killing thousands of innocent
civilians most significantly in Ireland where he remains a hated figure.
Cromwell would set his son Richard to be his successor who did in fact succeed
him in 1658 the republic would not last long after this,
that we would fall into instability marked by division and conflict.
Two years later in 1660 they would invite Charleston second to return to England
to rule as king and settled disputes.
Charles agreed to part in many of those who had betrayed his father,
but upon his return did execute around 50 people including post humorously
beheading the body of Oliver Cromwell.
Charles is second following the strict puritan rule of Chroma with referred to
as in Merrie monarch being seen as having a more hedonistic lifestyle than its
predecessor.
Though he favored religious tolerance,
seeing what religious intolerance had done to this country,
he agreed to the Clarendon code which encouraged submission to the Church of
England.
All the while England's colonies in North America continue to grow in England
would claim territory in this time in Africa and near India as well.
Despite his agreement to Clarendon Code.
Charles.
A second toward the end of his reign was having Catholic leanings and in fact
named a Catholic air.
England was divided over this issue.
Again,
two sides rose up in the debate over the issue of succession.
A group called the wigs demand at the James.
His Catholic Aaron brothers should indeed be excluded from succession and the
Tories believed that he should succeed him.
Parliament was outrageous over Charles.
His decision,
but much like his father Charles called together and dissolved parliament
multiple times on his death bed.
On the 6th of February,
1685 Charles converted to Catholicism and was succeeded by his brother.
The Duke of York was open,
the Catholic becoming James the second after facing conflicts in rebellion over
Catholic air,
the English people breathe a sigh of relief.
Finally,
as James is error was named to be his Protestant daughter Mary,
who had married William of orange stockholder of the Netherlands.
James changed his mind though and named his Catholic sun air to the sandwich.
Quite naturally angered William and Mary William attempting to secure a
succession as well as preventing an alliance with Louis.
The 14th France who was expanding rapidly decided to invade England and James in
his line were deposed in what is remembered as the glorious revolution.
William the third and Mary,
the second pass the bill of rights,
which guaranteed a number of rights to English citizens for granted,
the return of an absolute monarchy,
which many in England feared and also prevented a Catholic from becoming the
monarch of England.
The Catholics weren't finished with England yet though many English and
couldn't.
The Jacobites would attempt to restore Catholic monarch on a throne leading to
the Jacobite rebellions,
which would occur soon,
but later in English history,
William was succeeded by queen and the first A.
Dot.
R James is second,
but of course a protestant.
It was under her rule that the acts of union had been passed,
which essentially finally merge Scotland and England into a single nation before
this,
for the past hundred years.
Remember I had said that they were two nations with the same monarch after this,
they were really politically one nation.
They merged on a deeper level,
sharing not only a monarch,
but the same parliament and altogether government and Queen and accordingly
styles herself,
ruler of Great Britain and Ireland,
and his reign was also marked by England moving toward a two party system.
The wigs and the Tories,
which I,
which I mentioned earlier,
as well as Britain's role and the Spanish war of succession,
and an a dynastic conflict which lasted for 13 years and engulfed in much of
Europe during this war.
England McGann,
a territory of Gibraltar on a southern part of Spain,
which it retains to this day.
Also notable about this war in reference to England is that it was fought on
multiple fronts in North America.
It was the same more,
but it was referred to as Queen Anne's war.
Now,
this is not the first time that England wasn't an international conflict
involving its colonies,
but it just goes to show that in this war and in fact in a significant number of
England's of warrants for the next few hundred years,
when England goes to war with another European nation especially,
it's not always confined to just Europe.
It means that war might break out in north and South America,
in Asia and Africa across the ocean is essentially,
these are now global conflicts.
Queen Anne,
who had suffered from poor health from much of her life died in 1714 as the last
two were at monarch.
The wigs believe that parliament should choose the next English monarch when the
Tories favor to hereditary role has it always had been.
She was succeeded by George.
The first was a lector of Hanover who began to Hannah Varian House.
George was Ann's cousin who had the best claim technically to his throne with
respect to English law at the time,
meaning the large amount of potential Catholics.
The assessors who had perhaps a better claim to the throne had no hope.
George,
who did not even speak English,
did not possess much power.
In fact,
during his reign,
most political power would go to the rising position of prime minister held by
Robert Walpole.
Accordingly,
George would spend much of his time back in Hanover and with German figures of
the day.
Georgia successions sparked Jacobite rebellions and invasions from France as
they would attempt to put to the center of the Stewart Line,
James Edward Francis Stewart,
whom they believed would what protects Catholic interest if not lead it,
returned to Catholic England.
The rebellions in invasions failed and in 1727 George the first would be
succeeded by his son George.
That's second after centuries of England dealing with foreign monarchs.
Georgia's second will be the last monarch to be born outside of England.
He was of course,
born in Hanover,
though the following monarchs were native born.
They were perhaps a bit too cozy at home is Georgia's second was also the last
English monarch to lead an army into battle during the war of Austrian
succession.
Another messy dynastic conflict and global conflict of that in which Britain
joined forces with Austria,
the Dutch and Russia against France,
Spain,
and pressure as well as other powers.
George was much more focused on warfare during his reign.
Then his father had been in 1754 following the mess left during other conflicts
like the Borup Austrian succession.
The seven years war erupted,
the seven years' war,
which was actually nine years long,
but picked up more so from 1756 at 1763 is often remark as being a first true
world war Britain pressure and Portugal join forces with some other European
powers against France,
Austria,
Russia,
Spain,
and their allies.
It was fought in Europe,
in North America,
where does coming known as the French and Indian war here in this theater,
the French have Nouvelle France along with our native American allies,
fought against the British forces.
The results of the conflict here was for the future for North America and
responsible for the fate of nations like Canada and the United States and South
America.
Portugal and Spain would fight in India.
This war would be known as a third card knack tick war where Britain and France
would fight over the control of India.
This too,
it's about the future for India,
the east India company,
which was formerly intended to be focused on trading in the,
it was now preoccupied with conflict against France and securing a military and
political position in India and Africa.
Britain would attempt to take control of a French outpost on the continent there
as well.
So from Canada,
the long way around the world to the Philippines,
the seven years' war was fought on five continents,
principally between Britain and it's arch-nemesis France,
whom they had.
I'm sure you've noticed in conflict with from much of the century to the point
at which historians often called the 18th century,
the second hundred years war because Britain would fight with France for the
majority of it.
And also keep in mind,
I'll use England and Britain interchangeably at this point because of the
equivalency of the two,
but the p the correct political entity at the time here is the Kingdom of Great
Britain.
As was mentioned,
the war ends in 1763 with a victory on this side of Britain and its allies
officially with the treaty of Paris in North America.
France is largely expelled from the mainland that were retained.
Some North American territory's as its territory is seated to Britain beginning
Britain's oppression of the French Canadian natives.
Though the Louisiana territory was given to Spain in India.
France was not necessarily completely defeated.
Though Britain very much did maintain the upper hand and this seemingly endless
power struggle between Britain and France.
Britain was for the moment on top though there would be many conflicts to come.
During the seven years' war in Georgia.
Second had died and was succeeded by his grandson,
Georgia.
Third would reign for 60 years longer than any monarch proceeding him around the
time of the end of the seven years' war in toward the third ascension to the
throne,
a revolution was beginning to come to life.
Debatably beginning in England,
the industrial revolution,
the industrial revolution debated.
We began in England and the 1760s a technological revolution which moves
products which were hitherto produced by hand,
two machines.
This would cause over the next few centuries and unprecedented population growth
and improvements and general quality of life and availability of goods.
Though Georgia thirds rain was initially marked by success,
it would not remain so steady in North America.
Britain place taxes on its colonists to pay for reparations from the French and
Indian war.
Though the tax is placed on them were lower than those of the natives.
Native British inhabitance.
The North American colonists felt indignant at being subject to under British
law then taxes without equal representation and their parliament as was promised
in the English bill of rights,
the British would not budge and would attempt to suppress the American
colonists,
how the colonists would continue their resistance and efforts,
which would eventually lead to the American war of independence,
which would begin in 1775 but what be made official in 1776 the British held the
upper hand for the first part of the war.
Significantly,
as American colonists lacks significant resources to fight a war,
especially against the British empire,
those resources would come two years later is France.
I entered into the war on the side of the Americans,
Spain too.
In some way,
the Dutch would enter on the American side in order to attempt to subdue
Britain.
In 1783 Britain was following the siege of Yorktown defeated and was forced to
recognize the independence of the United States.
Britain though it retained Canada as Canada had remained loyal during the war,
had now lost the most significant chunk of its American empire,
and as a result,
but now come to focus on new frontiers leading to what is called the second to
British empire in a medium between American representative John Adams and King
George.
The third following the end of the war,
George the third is recorded to have said to Adams,
I was the last to consent to the separation,
the separation having been made and having become inevitable.
I have always said,
as I say now,
that I would be the first to meet the friendship of the United States as an
independent power.
Following the American revolution,
George would suffer mental health issues,
which would worsen throughout his life with the focus on new frontiers
thereafter.
For example,
in 1788 the British claim land in and found that a penal colony with about a
thousand people in Australia previously discovered by Captain James Cook.
This came largely from the fact that Britain's prison population is becoming
excessive and America,
it's former penal colony had declared its independence much like in America,
British settlers would clash with the native inhabitants for much of the
colonization process,
but Britain would retain a hold on Australia and later New Zealand and the
colonies would to grow.
Though the French had successfully taking revenge on Britain from the loss of
their American colonies by assisting the United States and the revolution.
Their efforts there as well as ms managements of their monor came both the
political and in fact meteorology climate of the day.
And by that I mean the devastating winters at France at face led to a revolution
in 1789 at first,
Britain did not have a firm reaction to the French revolution,
but eventually when the revolutionaries beheaded King Louis,
the 16th Britain became considerably worried.
France,
a major European power was now transitioning into our public and not only
Britain,
but in fact a majority of European powers felt it necessary to take measures
against Republican efforts in order to secure their Thrones and prevent any such
movements in their countries.
When France declared war on the nations which are perceived as a threat to their
revolution.
Britain form the first coalition with Austria,
Prussia,
and other major European powers as the various powers of Europe fought with and
may piece with friends individually on multiple occasions in the first and
second coalition,
Britain remained staunchly and and a meat of the French revolution throughout
its duration.
For instance,
tempt it to incur insurrection in Ireland,
but it failed soon after.
On January 1st,
1801 the first day of the 19th century,
George the third in his prime minister at the time,
William Pitt merges Ireland into a single state along with England,
Wales and Scotland,
now known officially as the United Kingdom of Great Britain and Ireland.
Now,
Ireland was in the same political union at Scotland had entered into a hundred
years ago.
Unlike Wales and Scotland.
Ireland,
however,
had remains predominantly Catholic.
William Pitt considered removing certain legal restrictions placed on Catholics
in the United Kingdom of the day,
but Georgia third refuse maintaining Protestant authority.
The French Revolution had come to an official end two years prior in 1799 but
Britain refuse to see it that way.
Napoleon Bonaparte,
a French general,
had led a coup d'etat and seize power in France,
but Britain remained at war with them.
In 1801 Britain agreed to a piece,
but Georgia third in his government had no intention of allowing a lasting peace
and what's more.
Napoleon had clearly no intentions of remaining dormant war resumed in 1803
entering Britain into the Napoleonic wars,
a series of conflicts which would last until 1815 in which Britain would remain
Napoleon's arch-nemesis Britain had throughout this war and throughout much of
the 18th century in fact,
and army,
which was considerably inferior,
that at France,
Napoleon's army,
for example,
during the Napoleonic wars,
but grow to be five times as large as Britain's and an arguably better equipped.
Why would Britain allows such a tip and the scale?
Because the British ruled the seas,
they must definitely had a superior navy and as an island,
nation,
France or any other of Britain's rifles,
they didn't have much of a shot at threatening Britain or disrupting his contact
with any of it's overseas colonies.
Because of this very powerful on challenged navy,
France though would attempt to challenge Britain's naval superiority and would
plan to invade the island in 1805 the British navy under the command of Lord
Horatio Nelson and engage the French and Spanish ships planning the invasion off
the coast of Spain.
The British engage them in until they've lost 500 men,
including Lord Nelson himself.
They did not lose a single ship.
The Spanish and French lost 22 ships.
Lord,
his last words are recorded as thank God I have done my duty following this.
Napoleon would concentrate his efforts on the continent,
but even during the height of his empire,
Britain would remain a Thornton to point side.
Britain quite naturally finance the points.
Enemies and Napoleon responded by banning trade with Britain across as empire,
but this would backfire hurting Europe's economy.
Morgan Britons who is navy,
allowed it to break through restrictions placed by their French and cause much
of Europe to resent the full eight and Britain was engaged in other conflicts
during his time as well,
such as the war of 1812 with the United States,
which ended in a stalemate as well as indirect campaigns against the point and
war with Denmark and the Netherlands.
But a chance came from more direct confrontation against Napoleon in Spain.
Spain rose up against French occupation and Britain in Portugal rose up to join
them leading to the peninsular war.
Napoleon was losing to Anglo Iberian forces largely again,
that's command of the Duke of Wellington.
During this war,
Napoleon made a catastrophic mistake.
I'm invading Russia where he was greatly to feed his enemies,
closed in from the east with Britain now invading the south of France from Spain
in 1814 friends was forced to surrender.
Following this,
Napoleon was exiled to the island of Elba near Italy and Britain and its allies
restore the Bourbon King Louis the 18th the French thrown and redrew the borders
of Europe and the Congress of Vienna.
And here is a map of what those borders.
It looks like Napoleon was not done though.
In 18 and 15 he returned and what is known as a hundred days Napoleon's come
back rested upon winning a battle against the coalition against him and at that
battle,
the battle of Waterloo engage in British Prussian and other European forces.
Napoleon,
however,
was once again to feed it in this time,
exiled to the island of Saint Halena well off the coast of Africa where he died
six years later in 1821 during the Napoleonic wars she worked with third had
finally succumbed to his mental illness permanently in 1811 his son,
Georgia fourths or of this prince regions until his father died and became king
in 1820 with Napoleon defeated Britain and in fact much of Europe was now moving
toward a new era.
The congress of Vienna had achieved a balance of power in Europe between the
major powers of the day,
Britain,
France,
Austria,
Prussia in Russia,
the points republican ideals swept through Europe causing liberal uprisings in
many of the nations there several powers attempted to suppress them,
but Britain,
which had been traditionally more democratic than its counterparts,
embraced many of them throughout the 19th century.
It was toward the end of the reign of Georgia third in the beginning of Georgia
forest at the king's ministers rather than the king himself with dictate the
direction of the government along with parliament.
Britain would also end slavery threat it's empire in the early 19th century and
in fact would make attempts to relocate these slaves to their colony of Sierra
Leone in Africa.
The industrial revolution was taking root in Britain with France knocked out of
the way.
Britain was free to enter into what it would have remembered as its imperial
century and we had expanded its empire considerably across the globe becoming at
its height,
the largest empire the world had ever seen.
While Britain was busy across the globe,
though the rest of Europe remained in a moderate level of peace.
Conflict on the scale of the Napoleonic wars would not be seen again until 1914
which is why the imperial century 1815 to 1914 is also to as packs for Tanika.
The British piece.
Britain now had a considerable interest in expanding into Asia.
It had already moved in on India,
Southeast Asia,
and most of Oceania and other nearby areas in the Middle East.
Now with the Ottoman Empire,
Persia and China all in decline,
the British empire saw their opportunity to expand to a greater degree.
Britain was not entirely unrivaled in the century,
however,
especially in Asia,
where they competed with Russia over the control of Central Asia for much of the
19th century and what is known as at the great game,
direct and indirect conflict with Russia would manifest itself in multiple wars.
In 1837 at the age of 18 Victoria became queen of Britain and of the British
empire following death of king blame.
Fourth being a woman.
However,
she was barred from succeeding him to the throne of Hanover.
Victoria would reign over Britain until 1901 during the better part of its
imperial age.
Her early rain was marked by complex across the world in China.
The first opium war conflict between the Ching Dynasty in Britain named after
opium.
The drug which many Chinese were worryingly addicted to that Britain eagerly
supplied was fought.
A few years later,
the first Afghan war war,
a part of the great game with Russia would erupt during Victoria's reign.
England would begin to truly modernize quality of life increase as medicine and
science expanded railways in such forms of transportation were introduced it to
country,
world empire spread new products across the globe.
Workers' movements would reform the poor conditions of labor in the country.
English culture would progress and spread across the world,
including the English language,
which today remains the dominant world language.
They'll not the most spoken England would expand and as South Africa,
parts of Latin America,
Egypt and other parts of the Middle East and Southeast Asia.
The population of England,
Wales and Scotland would double the population of Britain's Australian colony
would explode during this time too.
During the Victorian gold rush,
though,
places such as Ireland would suffer feminine emigration.
In fact,
Ireland's population during this time would be cut in half color over killed
nearly 2000 people a week in the UK in poverty would accompany this population
explosion.
Meanwhile,
the eastern question was posed upon European powers.
The Ottoman empire was in decline and a power vacuum had to be procured by
someone.
This is what led as mentioned to Britain occupying territory such as Egypt in
the southern part of the Arabian peninsula,
but more important to the British was keeping the Russians out of the Ottoman
decline.
This would lead to the Crimean war.
In 1854 Britain teamed up with France and the Ottoman Empire against Russia in
its brief interval impacts Britannica.
Though Britain and its allies would end up winning the war.
The British people were largely against it and protested British intervention,
the original borders before the war,
we'll restore it,
but Russian influence in the region significantly declined as a result allowing
Britain and France and secure the remains of the dying Ottoman Empire.
In 1858 phone revolt and unrest,
Britain decided to annex India entirely.
Victoria subsequently took on the title Emperor of India in the 1860 [inaudible]
during the American civil war,
Britain considered intervening to assist itself even though the north was
supported largely with the British populous,
largely because of trade.
It's southwest producing quite a bit of cotton for which Britain used when
American president issued the emancipation proclamation.
However,
and slavery became a key issue of the civil war,
Britain abstained and not wanting to support slavery,
which they had already outlawed earlier that century.
This was just one example of the fact that Britain was to the joy of some and
disdain of others playing the role of global policemen.
At this time in history in 1879 the Anglos Zulu warrior began as a British,
instigated a war with a nearby Zulu Katen them in north occupy more of southern
Africa,
the Zulus where to feed it,
but the board republics,
which for African nations set up by former Dutch colonists.
No longer relying on Britain for protection from the Zulus.
Soon we're threatened by British domination of the region leading to the Boer
wars and the first borough war.
The British were to feed it and the more republics maintained independence.
These conflicts were a predecessor of the scramble for Africa.
The scramble for Africa was essentially an event in which Africa was divided
between European powers.
Prior to this,
only some areas on the continent have been occupied by Europeans.
Following this,
the mal came to look like this.
Much of Africa was divided amongst Britain,
France,
Belgium,
Italy,
Germany,
Portugal,
and Spain with only Ethiopia,
the dervish state in Liberia.
I remaining independent.
Ethiopia would eventually succumb to Italy in the Second World War.
However,
and Liberia was a nation established by the United States for formerly enslaved
Africans to return to in case you were wondering.
British colonies are shown in red.
As you can see,
they along with France controlled much of the continent,
which is of course why much of Africa today speaks English and French.
Looking here though was sued vest Africa.
By this time Germany had United into this single country and was the rival of
Britain and age where nationalist sentiments part across the Europe.
Pressure here caused Britain to move to annex and Bora Publix and the second bar
war.
Britain could not brag about having a union jack flying from Cairo to Cape Town,
both Germany and the United States at this time,
both threatened to take brands position as the industrial power of the world and
France and other European powers are main constant threats as well.
On top of this across Europe,
this nationalist sentiment,
as I said,
was creating tension.
Victoria died in 1901 at the age of 81 thus bringing an end to her era.
She was succeeded by her son who became Edward.
The seventh ushering in the Edwardian era.
Victoria was the last monarch of the Hana variant house.
The Edwardian era would witness another time period of great change.
Technologically,
the world was being introduced to things like airplanes,
cars,
and other inventions,
scientific discoveries.
Women were beginning to organize for their right to vote and other social
movements were beginning to sprout.
However,
on the darker side for England,
Ireland was beginning to press for independence from the British empire and
worsen this.
Europe was edging closer to the bloodiest war it had ever seen.
World War One.
In 1914 rising nationalism,
industrialism and imperialism and the Western world would finally come together
to explode into the Great War marketing the end of Britain's imperial century
and it's entrance into a new era.
Following the assassination of archduke Ferdinand of Austria and Serbia,
the Austrian Hungarian Empire declared war on Serbia.
Russia responded,
declaring war on Usha.
Germany came to the aid of us.
Your France came to the aid of Russia.
Germany then invaded France and Belgium and Britain joined Fred's and Russia
side and the Ottoman Empire joined war in Germany,
Austria side and the World War one was does set to engulf the whole continent.
The alliance in Britain,
France and Russia,
their colonies and other nations such as Serbia,
Japan,
and Italy are often referred to as the allied powers.
Germany,
Australia Ottomans and their allies in colonies were known as a central powers.
The population of the British empire rally together for war or so.
The propaganda said the British were draw forces from Canada,
New Zealand,
South Africa,
Australia,
India,
and the rest of its empire to fight on the emerging western front as well as
against the Ottoman Empire in the Middle East.
Some were more willing to go than others in Ireland.
Support for independence was beginning.
An Irish nationalists abrogated by conscription and believing Britain to be
distracted by the war rose up attempting to declare independence.
The effort failed,
but it would not be the last one in Quebec,
Australia and other parts of the empire.
Konis supporting the war that they didn't feel personally involved in fighting
under flag of which they question their loyalty would sow the seeds for disorder
in later parts of the century during World War One anti German sentiment would
lead to the house of sacs,
Colbert in Carthage to change their name to the house of Windsor,
which remains to this day.
World War One would in many ways modernize the British military machine,
guns,
tanks,
poison gas,
some marines and other such technologies enter the scene.
The utilization of airplanes led to the founding of the Royal Air Force.
By the end of the war,
the British army had increased in size by 25 times its original.
I've mentioned throughout this video wars which Britain had fought such as the
seven years' war or the Napoleonic wars were arguably the first rolled wars,
but they pale in comparison to the strain and level of conflict that world war
one place on the entire world.
The western front on which Britain,
France would fight against.
Germany became a stagnating killing field.
Both sides dug trenches and endeavor that safety enemies trench.
This would go on for months with neither side getting large amounts of grounds.
All the while millions would die on the sea.
However,
Britain held obvious superiority,
defeating Germany on multiple occasions in 1917 Russia to come to the first
Republican,
but then communist revolutions,
it would be forced to drop out of the war.
Germany could no focus its effort on the west,
which concern Britain and France that same year,
however,
the United States of joy and the allies against the central powers,
the United States was not yet the military machine on a scale that Britain,
France,
and Germany had been,
but they didn't have to be.
Their military was fresh.
The country's wealthy industrial and and ravaged by the war that had that thus
far torn Europe apart and that made their intervention crucial.
The allies pushed into the central powers and the war ended on the 11th hour of
the 11th Day of the 11th month.
In 1918 Britain had lost slightly over a million people and combined with the
Spanish flu which had the country in 1918 world war one itself was a devastating
or a deal to all of Europe.
Though Britain was admittedly better off than most nations on the main
continents,
the empires and monarchies of Germany,
Austria or Russia,
and the Ottoman Empire had all collapsed.
Many new nations arose following the peace.
Treaties and Europe began to gradually change.
Following the treaty of Versailles,
Britain and especially friends focused on weakening Germany and preventing
another conflict of equivalent scale.
Unfortunately,
the term said Britain and France and placed on Germany.
We're rather vindictive and placed on them with the intention of blaming Germany
for everything that had happened.
When in reality,
perhaps no single nation or more broadly now,
there's side was entirely to blame for the war.
Britain and France absorbed Germany's colonies.
Through this,
Britain would be absorbed 13 million new subjects and would rise to its height
remaining.
To this day,
the largest empire which has ever existed at this height,
it would rule over a significant portion of the world's population and
controlled nearly one fourth of its land mass.
Here is the map of that empire.
Quite a long way to come from feuding Anglo Saxon tribes,
Frances Empire to would grow following the war.
Though other allies like Italy and Japan fell to their efforts,
were not properly compensated,
leading to resentment and along with anger and embarrassment,
and Germany's sowed the seeds for the conflict.
As the British Empire entered into his post World War One era,
many things will begin to change.
The the British empire had grown significantly.
It was beginning to weaken and some of its core areas,
many colonies such as India began to question his loyalty to the empire began
independence movement Ireland rose up in their ward if independence against
Great Britain eventually gaining that independence in 1922 though are they
remained a dominion of the British Empire for some years after that.
Northern Ireland,
however,
which consisted of Protestants loyal to England was not in the same boat as the
rest of our lineage.
Siding against independence movements and in fact to this day remains a part of
the United Kingdom.
Egypt to would gain a significant amount of independence during the 20s somewhat
argue that Britain due to social reforms,
was experiencing improved quality of life.
Wish had hitherto not been seen.
There was also a social changes throughout the 20s as following the darkness of
World War One,
people became considerably more hedonistic and loose.
However others point out,
the lacking state of the British economy,
Britain was falling behind the United States as the world industrial power.
Though Britain saw the United States has more of a friend than a rival.
Britain had other enemies on the horizon to worry about.
Militaristic governments have taken power in Germany and Italy and Japan on the
one side on the other with relation to the Great Depression that hit Britain and
thirties and more severely in other parts of the world.
Fear of the failure of capitalism was encouraged by the rising Soviet Union and
their intention to spread communism.
In January of 1933 Germany had elected an Austrian war veteran named ad off
Hitler to be their leader through repair the disgrace of Germany following World
War One Hitler was successful in revitalizing Germany,
but he was not satisfied with that alone.
He wanted to empower Germany to be a major European power and expand its power
throughout the world.
In contrast,
of course to the will of Britain,
France and the other allies,
Germany broke several of the restrictions placed on it from the treaty of
Versailles,
but France and Britain,
if you're in the outbreak of another great war,
allowed him leniency and what's what is referred to as their policy of
appeasement.
In reality,
by failing to act quickly,
they may have allowed another world war to be inevitable.
Germany sign alliances with Italy and Japan and it was when Hitler invaded
Poland in 1939 that Britain and France flight of the cleared war leading to
World War Two the great majority of Europe fell at the German Nazi empire.
By late 1940 even France would fall within a matter of weeks.
Despite expectations that war on the border with France could last few months,
if not years.
How does as a hat in world war one with the Soviet Union still remaining
neutral,
only the British empire would resist leading to the battle of Britain,
which was the largest aerobatic ever seen during this time.
Winston Churchill who favored a more aggressive policy toward Germany than the
Neville Chamberlain.
His predecessor became prime minister.
He issued many words of encouragement to the British people.
We should fight,
fight on the beaches,
on the landing grounds.
We can fight in the field ended in the street,
which we'll never know.
Sharonda soon Britain was alleviated from varying the burden of the German
empire.
As Germany invaded the Soviet Union,
Russia would join the allied side.
When Japan attacked both British Malaysia and American for Pearl Harbor,
the United States would join the war as well.
On the allied side,
Britain was no engaged in conflict in Europe,
North Africa,
in the Mediterranean,
and the Pacific Ocean.
The most significant failure here was a fall of the stronghold of Singapore,
the Japanese,
which push the British believe to be an impenetrable one.
The surrender was referred to by Winston Churchill as the worst disaster in
British military history,
British failure and the Pacific would lead Australia and New Zealand to
coordinate their efforts more with the United States and the support to the
United States and Soviet Union would be decisive factor in switching the balance
of power from the access to the allies.
Gradually,
they would begin to gain the upper hand in June of 1944 who allied forces and
Britain,
United States,
Canada,
Australia,
and the resistances of occupied European nations invaded German,
held Norman eat and what is known as a d day invasion.
These invasions came in tandem with the Soviet Union beginning to turn a war
round on the eastern front Britain in the United States and their allies pushed
and the western front,
the Soviets from the east.
As I said,
Germany was not being in close upon Japan.
Two was beginning to see its demise and the Pacific as the allies close into
Germany and then to Berlin.
In 1945 Hitler committed suicide.
Soon thereafter,
Germany unconditionally surrendered.
Japan would later surrender as well as allied victory.
It was secured nearly half a million people throughout the British and I'm
fireable soldiers and civilians had died in World War II.
These losses where significant though admittedly Britain hadn't much fewer
losses and other nations such as Germany or the Soviet Union,
Britain which was able to maintain its independence and empire throughout the
war,
did not emerge from it as cocky as it has been.
World War One,
world war two was the deadliest single conflict in human history and it had
reshaped the world significantly including the British Empire,
the u s n Ussr both oppose the European and therefore British colonialism.
But in order to slow the spread of communism and attempt to prevent it from
spreading into Britain's former colonies as its hold to them weekend,
US would support the gradual of Britain from its colonies rather than complete
total sudden independence as the u s took indirect control over many.
And the Soviets of course,
got to others.
Britain's tactic regarding the loss of its colonies was quite a bit different
than was seen with a nation such as France,
which fought brutal war is against many of his former colonies to try to retain
them.
Britain was more tolerant and accepting of the fact that it was losing control
over many of them.
Although Britain too,
it did feel a needs to retain some of its colonies such as the Suez Canal in
Egypt and when engaged in conflict.
There were some,
but again,
as I said,
not as significantly as a nation such as France.
Britain had accepted that it was no longer the world superpower,
but these efforts were undertaken with the intention of keeping Britain alive as
a major world power.
The Suez crisis in the early 1950s was indeed one of the British Empire's and
Francis for that matter.
The last attempts to retain its imperial authority throughout the world as it
failed,
the British attempts to reclaim the empire were largely bus pursuit,
especially as Canada,
Australia,
India,
and New Zealand.
Much of Africa and the Middle East and Southeast Asia had been lost most all of
them.
By the year 1970 these nations were still tied to Britain,
to the Commonwealth of nations which was formed as Britain declared as colonies
has equals to the United Kingdom.
In 1949 the Commonwealth remains to this day and Queen Elizabeth the second
England's current monarch remains the monarch of many nations,
including Australia,
Canada,
South Africa,
New Zealand.
Although this is of course traditional,
she didn't holds very little political influence in these nations back home in
Britain.
However,
life was not quite so bad.
The standard of living following the rebuilding after where the were up to,
but significantly raises leading many people from Britain's former colonies to
want to immigrate to Britain.
As I mentioned,
the withdrawal of European powers from their former colonies let the vacuums
which the United States and Soviet Union tried to fill as part of their tension
and rivalries,
referred to as the Cold War,
the United Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern Ireland as it was and is
referred to to to stay a lead member in the United Nations.
And a NATO,
the North Atlantic Treaty Organization and military alliance set up to counter
the Warsaw Pact was thrown into the midst of this cold war.
Britain would be involved in or state support for at least many of the United
States has conflicts during the war,
such as the Korean War into which Britain sent about 15,000 troops following the
50s and the 60s the economy of Britain was beginning to reach record levels of
unemployment and economic decline,
not sharing in the longevity of rejuvenation that the United States would enjoy,
and quite frankly,
it's still enjoying falling World War II.
Following the election of Margaret Thatcher,
the first female British prime minister,
the economy would take a turn upwards.
In 1991 the Soviet Union had fallen Britain,
which would a bear to significant amount of the fight in a potential military
confrontation with communist power,
which could have ultimately spiraled into a third world war or even a nuclear
war.
Breathe a sigh of relief.
Six years later.
In 1997 the British empire would come to an official and as Britain's
surrendered rendered Hong Kong to the People's Republic of China,
that same year,
Wales and Scotland were granted their own parliaments in recent times.
In fact,
Scotland has even made a bid for independence,
which would bring an end to the union held in place since James the first and
fourth the Scottish independence referendum about the endeavor for Britain to
leave the European Union referred to as Brexit in 2015 did not fail.
England today remains one of the world's most important nations as it deals with
a political disagreements,
economic crises,
world disorders and conflicts,
and all the troubles which plague our modern world.
Today,
it appears quite certain that England is not going anywhere from its position as
a respectable,
powerful,
dignified,
and distinguished nation,
and we'll most certainly play a role in things to come.
The history of England from tribal societies on a mysterious island without
writing to the largest empire the world had ever seen,
could not be truly respected within the time span of only around two hours,
which this video has taken the outline it,
but I hope that I have provided a sufficient outline into the major events in
continuous motion of England and its empire.
A history of which I find is not commonly addressed as one great spam,
but rather as isolated moments within the greater,
more complex history that we've outlined today.
The enduring effects and legacy of England and the British empire is
indisputably significant,
but admittedly controversial.
England retains a unique culture of beautiful and rich language is strong
identity.
It considers itself a protector,
freedom,
peace,
and other such ideals around the world.
In a shining example of western philosophy and civilization at home,
the British empire more than any other nation spread modern civilization across
the globe successfully along with its language and culture and things such as
that.
While many places in Africa,
the Middle East and Asia on Dolly benefited from British rule Wilner course to
modernization.
The ways in which Britain went about establishing the colonial rule.
A company frowned upon as it was often subjugation of local peoples was only at
the benefit of Britain in mind without much regard to the native benefit from
British rule.
Even within Britain regarding England's rural and countries like Scotland and
Wales and Ireland.
Questions have been raised about the morality of the role.
I won't go too far into these points beyond saying that unquestionably England
is responsible for greatly benefiting the world as well as being the perpetrator
of many things which we today would consider criminal that would encourage you
given the information provided here and for information from numerous other
sources,
but I encourage you to look into to form your own independent opinions regarding
the entirety of England and its empire.
I believe it's fair to say though,
without England,
the world would not be the place that it is today and England's history is
undoubtably.
Therefore worth exploring,
especially as we view England's decisions regarding the future.
For more videos like these and videos on many other subjects,
we should have checked out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.